[Music]
[Applause]
I mentioned this story earlier that it
is a bigger story outside the United
States and I'm surprised at this but
it's a bigger story in France has to do
with vikor wama putting himself into a
game Tuesday night he put himself back
in the game and then I think he had a
dunk and then pop took him
out didn't put him in Victor W bayama
checked himself in so it's a big story
in Victor W Bama's you know home country
of France Tom orsborne covers the Spurs
for the San Antonio Express News is this
going to be a bigger deal here
Tom hey Dan good morning um I as you
said yeah in France everything's a big
deal with Victor but here I think that
you know he's he stressed over and over
again that he's on board with the
minutes restriction that was placed on
him uh five games ago due to a series of
ankle tweaks um he's on board with it
but he he's growing frustrated with it
too because he really doesn't think he's
injured and and the Spurs love his
competitive fire they love the fact that
he wants to play um you know he'll play
every minute in every game if he had his
way he's he's super competitive and uh
you know he's he's durable despite his
frame you know he's tough he knows how
to fall it's amazing when you watch him
crumple to the floor he knows how to do
it it's kind of like Tom Brady when he
used to get sacked yeah but Tom he
checked himself into a game in front of
Greg bovic is that is that what
happened that's what happened he he had
lobbied you know they when they took him
out I don't know what it was I think it
was 16 points he had reached his minutes
limit ation of 25 minutes which was one
over the 24 that they said but he saw
that they kept they kept cutting into
the lead he thought they could win it
he's frustrated he's telling you I'm
okay let me what's another one or two
minutes let me back in and he just
slipped past pop checked himself in
actually got a dunk that cut it to eight
points with 147 left and then pop you
know said come on get out but did you
know what was Tom did you know what was
going on in that moment that he checks
himself into the game without you know
Pop's permission no no no he explained
it afterward that that he did it on his
own um you know he wasn't supposed to
sub in he subbed in pop you know I guess
he was we didn't get we we talked to
Victor after pop so it was kind of a um
you know we couldn't ask Pop about it
because we didn't know the story at the
time
I you know Pop's a
disciplinarian I don't know if if he has
fun with this it is this story
over I'm sorry about that Dan is is this
story
over um you know we'll be talking to VI
both Victor and pop about it today pop
pregame Victor after the game you know
pop Victor made it clear he wants you
know he would love to have the minutes
restriction lifted um pop said we got to
take some more MRIs you know take a take
a look reexamine his ankle their fear is
that it's been it's been tweaked so much
that the ligaments might be stretched
which makes him vulnerable to more
injury uh further injury makes him
susceptible so I would imagine sooner
rather than later they'll take that MRI
and um you know his the Restriction will
be lifted pretty soon I would think well
thanks for joining us we appreciate it
Tom anytime thank you Dan that's Tom
orsborne San Antonio Express covering
the Spurs to me it's pretty wild imagine
if any like how many players can check
themselves into a game I don't think
there are any rookies who can do that
and how many players could do that under
the watchful eye of Greg
papovich I just I can't imagine that